L'avortement doit être plus accessible en Europe.
Bon, il est déjà accessible partout.
L'Europe est en guerre contre l'islamisme.
Oui, l'Union européenne aide-le à masse.
Mais elle a raison.
Il faut interdire le mariage homosexuel.
C'était en tout cas 1 erreur de la story.
La civilisation européenne est supérieure aux autres,
elle a rayonnée à travers le monde plus que d'autres.
L'Europe doit s'excuser pour la colonisation,
non, on peut réduire l'immigration
sans sortir de l'Union européenne.
Oui, mon parti délaisse la question écologique.
Non, le hokis me détruit l'Europe.
Oui, les États-Unis sont les alliés naturels de l'Europe.
Oui, il faut mettre en place la rémigration,
c'est aujourd'hui 1 nécessité.
Oui, le racisme anti-blanc est 1 réalité.
Oui, malheureusement,
les immigrés subis du racisme en Europe.
Non, je ne le crois pas, ou ça peut exister marginalement.
Mais les
nations européennes sont les moins racistes du monde.
La Hongrie de Victor robban
est 1 modèle à appliquer pour la France
en partie. La guerre à Gaza est en génocide.
Le 1ère génocide,
c'est quand-même
l'abomination de l'attaque du Hamas contre l'Israël.
L'écologie est 1 valeur de droite.
Oui, c'est 1 vraie valeur de droite
qui a été dévoyée par la gauche.
Le déclin actuel de l'Occident est
comparable à la chute de l'empire Romain
à certains égards.
Oui, la Russie devrait être 1 allié plutôt qu'un ennemi.
Oui, idéalement,
mais elle se comporte comme 1 ennemi aujourd'hui.
Médine est proche des frères musulmans.
Oui, Ursula vanderlion tire l'Europe vers. Le bas,
oui, incontestablement.
L'union des droits se fera derrière. Jordan Bardella.
Non, je ne le crois pas.
Il peut y participer. En revanche.
La guerre de civilisation est 1 réalité.
On nous fait la guerre,
donc on est bien obligé d'accepter
de la mener et de la gagner.
Mon parti égoïste ?
Oui, euh. Gaulien. En tout cas,
l'Union européenne a répondu
correctement aux attentes des agriculteurs.
Non, euh. Elle répond rarement correctement aux attentes
des citoyennes. Mais en général.